hello to you bucky and a huge
congratulations
uh best actress nomination rising star
award nomination and the film
seven nominations leading the board
really quite a
fantastic day for you um thank you so
much
your first professional acting gig and
you're right up there
it's it's crazy i don't know it's um
it really is crazy i feel really blessed
and grateful
um i still fully can't really articulate
how i feel but um it's all amazing
for those who don't know your story
bucky you you were plucked out of your
classroom at school just
tell us what happened yeah so the
casting director
and director lucy pardy and sarah gavron
they were just at the back of our
performing arts classes and all the rest
of my friend me and my friends before
that it was like
ofsted or something but then after like
a year of them
of observing the back of our classes
they invited us to workshops and a few
of us came to the workshops
the workshops so slowly transformed into
all auditions
and then after like a year or so we were
allocated but
it was yeah it feels like such a it
feels like decades ago but
yeah it's amazing yeah i mean it's only
two years ago and how has this role
changed
your life um
i feel like it's completely shifted my
perspective
i think i've always believed that i was
the main character to my
own narrative my own life and i was just
trying to do this life
thing um trying to ultimately become an
adult and then do that adult thing but
then once i
started acting and started to jump into
someone else's narrative it just made me
become more sonder and just realize how
everyone's life is just so complex and
it's just so
there's just so much going on with
everyone so i guess this
situation completely shifted my
perspective made me much more mindful
and watchful
and then the women that i met during
this process were so
international and just so smart and just
so
amazing it made me want to be like them
and today's bafta nominations marked a
big shift
in the approach of bafta after last year
the controversy that it was so white it
was so
male do you think enough has been done
yet
you know i think i'm i'm so i'm a baby
in the industry i'm so new
this is my debut performance i'm just so
fresh
and i don't want to um speak
and be and then spew out information
when i'm still very new i feel like
once i do more readings and start to
understand the nuances of the industry
more
i feel like i'll have much more
something that's more substantial to say
but i do um i do appreciate
my experience in the industry and i do
love
my experience and then the way the women
have cradled me into
the industry and made sure that i
haven't felt the heat that people have
felt
previous years because i know it has
been a difficult road
for actors and actresses who have
similar attributes to me
so i guess i'm
i'm in like i'm in favor of what's right
and i'm excited for the future
i feel that change is happening slowly
but surely do you feel that those
barriers
that might have existed are starting to
come down
i think there's always going to be
barriers you know with everything
with any sort of job any sort of
occupation
but i do think because people are
working so hard and people are realizing
that there's room for everyone
like storytelling is so endless so
to kind of be a blockade to performers
it's a disservice to what storytelling
is
so i definitely think things are
loosening because people are realizing
that
there's just so many stories to be told
you've now become a role model to young
black girls who are your role models
some of my role models my role models
are my friends
my friends my brothers my parents my mum
music musicians d'angelo tupac biggie
jay-z
nina simone erie lennox my my role
models are the people who
inspire me um you see i've got posters
of like musicians on my wall because i
love hip-hop i love soul music
and that kind of informs everything i do
um
yeah i just the people who inspire me
are people that i
look up to amazing what a wise head
you have on those young shoulders bucky
backray a really really great
to talk to you congratulations again and
wishing you the very very best
of luck